i had a question from youtube they wanted to know
how do you get rid of sun spots i've done another
video on aging spots or liver spots and i'll put
that link down below and that talks mainly about
the hyper pigmentation that occurs if there
is three situations high insulin high estrogen
or high cortisol from stress but i didn't
actually do a video on the best remedy for
sun spots which is slightly different now these
little tiny cells in the skin called melanocytes
produce this pigment called melanin which gives
you the color of your skin and if you're exposed
to the sun too much you can develop these little
blemishes or dark spots to your skin now there's
a really good remedy for this that you can use
and it's basically licorice extract and you want
to get it in a tincture a liquid and you want
to make sure it's alcohol free and you want to
put it in a little spoon and put a couple drops in
there and mix it up and then apply it to your skin
you can also apply it underneath your eyes if you
have dark circles and it works pretty effectively
within a couple days licorice root does many
things it's a very powerful antioxidant it's an
anti-inflammatory it's used for stress digestive
problems and many other things but if you wanted
to get rid of your sunspots you might want to
try this because it's pretty darn effective
hey before you go real quick i have
a course entitled how to bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course
i want you to take it and here's why
here's you here is your environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here what about
strengthening your immune system that's what's
missing this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can tolerate
and resist your environment much better by
strengthening your own immune system i put
a link down in the description right down
below check it out and get signed up today